a estas personas detenidas lo que tal
vez los une Es según los reportes un
profundo rechazo por las instituciones
del estado alemán por el orden liberal
democrático que hay en la República
Federal alemana Cómo entender esto
cuando hay democracias y cuando hay
garantías civiles y sociales
Gracias Santiago gusto bueno es una
señal de alarma muy importante y muy
grave porque estamos hablando de un de
un intento de golpe de estado de este
desconocimiento a las instituciones
democráticas a la República Federal
alemana hay exmilitares hay diputados
hay digamos distintos grupos que
comulgan incluso con esta organización
quanón que fraguó este intento también
de asalto al Capitolio estadounidense El
Seis de enero del año pasado y no es un
caso aislado entonces hay que tomar esto
como una amenaza real a la democracia y
una crisis
democrática en en todo el mundo y en
particular en Europa el ascenso de la
extrema derecha
ha sido muy preocupante porque se le ha
tolerado se le ha normalizado se ha
permitido Incluso cohabitar en distintos
gobiernos
en Europa hay entre 15 y 16 estados de
la Unión Europea donde la extrema
derecha ha crecido de un quince hasta un
60% en los escaños es un es un asunto
para para
saltarlas a las alarmas en toda Europa
Señor guacoja usted habla de una amenaza
que no solamente en Alemania sino
también en otros países de la Unión
Europea Pero entonces en este momento
vale la pena analizar y reflexionar
sobre qué tan sólida Entonces está la
institucionalidad de estos países
europeos en este caso específico de
Alemania qué tan sólida está en este
momento La institucionalidad alemana
Bueno lo que sucede es que estamos ante
distintas crisis que se han ido
entretejiendo
la pandemia la invasión rusa Ucrania la
crisis económica temas que acentúan el
descontento ciudadano y el escepticismo
y hay una alejamiento de los gobiernos
hacia los ciudadanos los ciudadanos se
sienten abandonados incomprendidos y en
esa incomprensión muestran este enojo en
la búsqueda de unas alternativas
como son estas muy lejanas a la
institucionalidad y a la democracia pero
donde los discursos tienen cabida los
discursos extremistas sobre todo de
extrema derecha este populismo
excluyente que se ha expandido de manera
importante en distintos países de la
Unión Europea y el caldo de cultivo de
estas distintas crisis hace propicio que
tengan cabida estos estos discursos y
además Pues que se repliquen en
distintas partes de Europa e incluso que
se esté intentando exportar estas Estas
ideas hacia otras latitudes como el caso
de América Latina señor Cómo mejorar
entonces esa desconexión o ese
distanciamiento que hay entre los
estados los gobiernos los políticos y
las sociedades porque ese es un
escenario que no es solamente que se
esté presentando en Europa en este
momento en un país en una democracia
como en Alemania sino que también lo
vemos acá en la región de América Latina
donde hay una mayor vulnerabilidad dada
la precariedad de la institucionalidad
en algunos de los países entonces Cómo
mejorar esa conexión y evitar el
surgimiento o fortalecimiento de estos
grupos de ultraderecha
bueno el tema es que lo urgente hace que
se deje de lado lo lo importante y lo
importante se debe trabajar no se debe
dar por hecho que los valores como la
democracia el respeto a los Derechos
Humanos el estado de derecho están ahí y
que todo mundo está convencido de Ello
hay que reforzar hay que propagar y
sobre todo hay que convencer que estos
valores europeos estos valores
democráticos
son importantes no basta que estén ahí
en un tratado o en una constitución hay
que promoverlos día con día